-Tracy Morgan, everybody.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with more "Tonight Show."
That is the name.
We did the name of the book.
[ Hip-hop music plays ]
♪♪
-Yo, I seen your
"Finding My Roots," man.
You made me cry.
-Thank you.
-Mines come on
February 20th.
-Did you cry?
-Yeah, I broke down.
It don't matter who you are,
You going to break down?
They went back 400 years
in my family, man.
-Wow.
Wow.
-Really?
Yeah, man. Yeah.
Quest's family was found out,
they were the --
on the last slave ship
brought here.
His family.
-Yeah.
You got to watch that movie --
that show.
I mean, they have black --
black celebrities do it.
White celebrities, everybody,
you find out who you are.
And, like, when I got hit
by that truck,
I wanted to know who I am
before I leave this.
-Henry Louis Gates,
right, that's the host?
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah. Man.
-Skip.
Skip was great.
I mean, you should check out
his "Finding My Roots."
-Yeah.
-I will see that.
-It was very, very --
Oprah did it.
-Yeah.
-Barack did it.
-I want to do it.
-A lot of people did it.
-I want to do it, but I want...
-You should try.
They would love
to have you on, man.
It was two hours long.
And they give you
a book of life,
and they go back
on your father's side
and your mother's side,
400 years.
Yeah. Really?
So I know -- And guess who --
Guess who I found out.
-What?
-you know, the last --
the last thing they say
they want to know
who you're related to
that did this show,
right?
-Right.
-They asked you that, too.
-Yeah.
-And he said,
"Would you turn the last page,
Mr. Morgan?"
And I turn the page
guess who's sitting there.
My third cousin
on my mother's side -- Nas.
-Oh, yeah?
-Esco's my third cousin.
-I believe that.
-So, on the way back home,
I called him.
I said, "Guess what.
I did 'Finding My Roots.'"
He said, "I did it, too."
I said, "Me and you related."
He started crying.
I started crying.
And I said, "If you ever
need me, cuz, I'm there."
He said, "If you ever need me,
cuz, I'm there, right there."
But me and him was close anyway
because I did that
Comedy Central special
called "One Mic."
And that was because
his moms had passed away
and I dedicated
that to them.
-Oh, okay.
-Wow.
-To him and his mom, because
I'm really tight with Nas.
He's a really good man, too.
-He's a good dude.
-Yeah. He's righteous.
-I like Nas.
-Yeah.
I love you too, man.
-I love you, too.
-I mean,
me and you go way back.
Me and you go back like
spinal cords and car seats.
[ Laughter ]
We go way back.
Spinal cords and car seats.
That's my guy.
He's my younger brother.
[ Laughter ]
From a different mother
with a different color.
-You found that out
on "Finding My Roots"?
-We...
-We love --
We could have put all
this funny on TV, man.
-We can air this.
-When me and him be --
Like, when we have fun,
we just be --
It'll just be me and him.
We be in a zone.
I mean y'all, y'all are great.
We love y'all.
Y'all -- Y'all time, you give us
a time and everything.
But me and him
just be messing around.
-But do you remember
you gave me the limo ride?
-When I -- He wasn't even
on "Saturday Night Live," yet.
He was just a fan.
And I was going
to the after party
after the "Saturday Night Live."
And he was just like, "Yo, could
I ride in the limo with you?"
And I said, "Come on."
Him and his dad
and his mom
got in the limo with me.
-What?
-The next year he was on
"Saturday Night Live."
-No, dude, for real.
I was at "Saturday Night Live,"
and I was -- I go,
I don't know if I asked
to get into your limousine.
I was just like freaking out
that it was you.
I'm a fan. So I was like,
"Oh, my God, how you doing?
Nice to meet you."
And you go,
"You going to the party?"
And I go,
"We might if we can go."
-Let's go.
-You go, "I'll give you a ride.
Let's go right now.
Get in mine."
So me and my mom and my dad
got in your limousine
and went and sat
with Tracy Morgan at SNL.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now look at his life.
-The rest is history.